Oh, we're so weary. We've been talking our potions this way and that for weeks now, and we're so tired.
We've come to this town for a little thing called Constantinople.
I've heard you are the governor and his rat, and we are here to present you our potions in the hope that you will buy them.
Before I can taste your potions, I must ask, why is it Constantinople and not Istanbul?
Because we're in the renaissance period, that is how history works.
That historian checks out.
What do these potions do?
Well, so, we knew a number of towns ago, but there were signs that were printed, and we've lost them in the wind.
And now we do not know what the potions do, and they're all a very similar color, as you can see.
But we know that they all do good things.
Juggle them!
Juggle!
Let's throw the tomatoes.
You're going to let me try before you buy.
Do you really need potions?
I believe we do need potions.
One is for healing, one is for love, and one is explosive.
And the choice is yours.
Here we go.
Oh my god, it wasn't the explosive one.
It's clearly not the explosive one.
Let's do that a couple more times.
Oh my god.
Time!
I would like to taste first.
I, Sir Rick of the Rugby, with a name that's given to a dickhead who doesn't know how to taste potions,
That guy obviously sucks.
would like to try all the same.
Ah, this is not a potion of protection.
It's a potion of healing, or also of healing, from unoriginal, unspired craftsmen.
Okay, stop.
I would just have to give it a taste.
Here it goes.
Are you going to eat those?
I'm going to show it to you.
Whoa.
I feel quite attracted to you, my friend.
I'm going to give you the potion.
I'm not trying it, but I could be your king tonight.
Well, let's try the last one.
Jeez, there's only one left.
Well, we have to be sure.
I suggest you try it.
We will, we will, we will observe at a safe distance.
I, Sir Rick the Foolhardy, who could not taste his way out of a potion,
will give you a wet paper bag, and I'll see if this shall explode outside of setback.
And they're all dead.
Bravo!